in Washington the president faces the
strongest opposition from his own party
since he took office
many Republicans oppose his plan to put
tariffs on all Mexican goods they would
start next week at 5% and go up from
there unless Mexico does more to prevent
illegal border crossings Republicans
indicate they could vote to tie the
president's hands but he dismisses that
idea I don't think they will do that I
think if they do it's foolish there's
nothing more important than borders
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with
more on this story good morning to you
Nancy
why do you think the Republicans are
rebelling against the President on this
well because free trade Gail is a
longtime core Republican principle and
they say you hike tariffs on Mexico by
as much as 25 percent which is what the
president is threatening right now and
you simply end up charging American
consumers more for Mexican goods Senate
Republicans gave White House officials
an earful at a lunch meeting yesterday
urging them to reconsider or risk a
resolution of disapproval here Senate
leader Mitch McConnell there is not much
support in my conference for tariffs
that's for sure
will you try to block those tariffs what
I'm telling you is we're hoping that
that doesn't happen the United States
imported about 350 billion dollars worth
of goods from Mexico last year alone
tariffs could not only raise those
prices but they could threaten the
nearly 5 million US jobs that depend on
trade with Mexico mexico's foreign
minister is going to be sitting down
today with the Secretary of State and
the vice president he says he thinks
this can all be worked out but so far
Dana we haven't seen much indication
from the president that he's willing to
bend on this Nancy thank you very much